In each step of the migratory path of the
Great Human Expansion, humans founded a new area with
a small population. Now this illustration here is showing
you the great genetic diversity of the population here in
Africa, and then as a subset of the population
moved over here to the Middle East for the first
time. And colonize the area. Notice the reduced number
of people, but also the reduced genetic diversity. This randomly
selected group had a much smaller gene pool. There's
less allelic diversity than the bigger population over here
from where it came from. Of course, over the
generations, this allowed new alleles to gain a foothold. For
example, the purple allele, in this case, is the
most prevalent in this population. Whereas, over here, in the
original population. Purple is prevalent, but maybe not to
the same extent as it is in this new population.
This specific bottleneck effect right here. Reduced
genetic variation at each founding spot. It
happened again as humans moved outward, and
colonized new areas. Each time experiencing another
bottle neck. This altered the allelic composition
compared to the original population. Not only
from the population that it recently came
from, but the very original population out
of Africa. This special kind of bottleneck event is referred to as
a founder effect, because as you found a new area, a new founding
population, as you colonize an area, you have reduced genetic variability. So a
specific kind of bottleneck has occurred,
that's referred to as the founder effect.